oh hi everyone um
i'm here to tell you a story about how i
use deep learning for my image
recognition project
and well it didn't go very well but as
promised stay until the end to hear a
happy ending
um so to kick off uh a little bit about
me first
so i currently work at gocardless which
is a recurring payments provider
as a data scientist and here i create
machine learning products to reduce
payment failure rates
uh and reduce uh payoff road
as well but as a secondary thing i'm
also
a rock climber so this is a great
passion of mine recently
and it's a real shame i can't ask you
right now how many of you are aware of
climbing overall
or maybe tuned in to the stock uh just
because of climbing
uh but maybe you can let me know in the
q a afterwards uh
and i put a picture up here of me
climbing outdoors
if you haven't seen how that looks like
uh so this is outdoors but
actually might be more aware of indoor
climate because
that's become more popular recently and
how indoor climbing works is that you
you go to the climbing gym and you climb
routes that are kind of set by
professional route setters
and a route is just a sequence of
climbing holes
that is usually marked by a certain
color
and you would basically try to climb up
these holes to the top without falling
and once at the top you either jump down
or maybe you're using a rope if you're
going much higher up and then your
partner would lower you down
and the gyms do change the routes every
now and then so that you know you don't
need to climb
uh the same problem uh over and over
again
and each route would have kind of a
difficulty grading so not all problems
uh are the same and it goes from like
really easy introductory stuff that
everybody could do
to some like really elite level climbing
that maybe only some people in the world
are able to do so you might have heard
about adam andre
maybe one of the strongest climbers in
the world or alex ronald from the recent
movie
uh free solo and if you haven't
suspected yet
uh there's a reason why i'm talking so
much uh about all this climbing
and that's because the image recognition
problem to which i applied deep learning
i wanted to talk about
is related to climbing and that is
specifically
a side project that i've been working on
and it's an
app called cliencus and what you can do
with this app is
basically log the clients that you've
done
and even find information about them so
for example maybe how difficult uh
it is so the route will have a grade but
sometimes people disagree so maybe you
can see votes from that
or votes on how good the route is
because some some routes are more fun
than others
or perhaps even get some tips of how to
succeed at a client if
if you're struggling with it uh the app
is not available on app stores uh yet
we're selectively
working on it uh so you won't find it
that but uh
do let us know um if you're interested
and get in touch maybe even test it out
for us too
uh but why do this app what's the
motivation behind it
and the reason we decided to work on it
is because
there are apps already where you can log
that i have climbed a v1 problem
so for example in this image i've
climbed this
this route but if your friend came along
and climbed another deep one
you wouldn't know whether it's the same
v1 that you climbed
or whether it's a different one because
there can be multiple
problems in the gym with the same grade
so there is nothing in the system to
match those two routes together
there's only some description around it
but there is no kind of unique
identifier to say
this is the same route the route that
you climbed is the same route as your
friend did
whereas if you could match them together
imagine all the things that you could do
with that
share information maybe see some tips
about this route so it wouldn't be just
a log book anymore but
you could actually share information
about those
about those routes and that's when it
struck me
that i could use some machine learning
techniques
to solve this problem and actually use
image recognition techniques on a
picture of a hold
in order to match the two together
because when climbers come into the gym
they look at the route they kind of
visually recognize this as the same
route so by taking a picture of it
i could i could train a model that could
actually do this matching for me
and actually i have played around with
classification with tensorflow before
and was looking for a project to put
these skills into good use
and progress in that area further and
this was also a climbing related project
so another reason i was super excited
about it and
it was kind of when i thought about this
idea i kind of immediately wanted to
jump on it and start developing a model
so before jumping into the model one
more trick uh that's worth explaining
is about how do we ask users to take a
picture of a route
because as i said initially you know the
route
is a sequence of holes going up to the
top of the wall how do you take a
picture of that would you
ask the user to try to fit the whole
wall uh or the whole route in one
picture but you can imagine that that
might end up being quite inconsistent
and the image would likely contain
multiple routes so how do we know which
one the user referred to but a trick we
found that
works quite well here is to actually ask
the user to take a picture of the
starting hold
so usually when you come to climb a
problem it's actually quite obvious
which ones are going to start with
and you know if it's a little bit
ambiguous maybe take the biggest
starting hole so to make it even more
obvious
um so so these these kind of uh study
holes
they might repeat themselves but they
don't tend to that much so it should
work as a unique identifier for the
route
and looking at some of these examples of
starting
holes here so these are all different
pictures but of the same hold
we can kind of start imagining that okay
a model perhaps can be trained on these
images to say that okay these two holes
refer
to this route these two holes refer to
this route and perhaps you would you
know try to get multiple
images uh off of the same climber hole
to give even more data to
the model so to quickly recap because i
realized there's quite a lot of
information going on
what's the idea behind the app and and
what's the user flow
uh so basically a user climbs a route
and they want to
log what they've done or find
information about it so with their
mobile
phone using the app they take a picture
of that starting bolt
and that image is then fed to the model
and the model is basically trained on
all the routes available in the gym
standing holds of those routes and is
then able to predict
provided a starting hold which route
that image belongs to so basically
provided this image
would get fed into the model and it
would identify that okay
this uh this looks like route one so i
will return this prediction to the user
and show all
the information that we have uh about
this route
um so that's the idea now how
about how do we go about actually
training this kind of model
so if you know anything about machine
learning and training models you
probably know that the first step
is getting the data for it and what i
did here is i basically gather the group
of friends and we all went to
uh the gym together and took a bunch of
pictures so i was really lucky that
we did this before the lockdown before
all the gyms closed
um so i had the data to work with
so basically we all went around and took
pictures of the biggest starting holes
kind of doing it in a realistic manner
so i didn't tell them which
you know uh hold i took a picture of so
make it as realistic as possible
and we all did this for the evening and
basically got
pictures of 46 different routes uh in
the gym
and in total i had just over 300 images
in total so multiple images per route in
order to train the model better
and i then split it into different uh
data sets in order
to kind of test the validity of my model
so i had a train set that i fed to the
model
uh and also a validation test while i'm
developing the model and finally a
tester to do a final
comparison so how do i go about
training a model like that so because
i've played around with tensorflow and
kind of thought that
this is uh this is a good problem to use
deep learning on
um because i'm dealing with uh image
data
uh i wanted to train a neural net
basically and you can imagine that
if you've heard about deep learning is
that usually you need a lot of data to
train a neural network model and here i
just said i've got 300 images
that's not a lot right so but actually a
trick that you can do
with deep learning is that you can use a
pre-trained model
which is strange on like maybe a million
images already
and only use your images on top of that
model
in order to tell the model what kind of
prediction i'm expecting or maybe
fine-tune
the last few layers of that model but
actually starting with a base
which is quite good and can detect color
can detect certain features it's
a little bit like starting with a child
who already knows something about the
world rather than cytokine completely
from scratch so
i used a vgg 16 pre-trained
convolutional base
for that i also use data augmentation
which is basically
introdu making my dataset bigger
artificially
by taking the images that i have but
rotating them
cropping them perhaps changing the
brightness
in order to make my data more varied and
help the model learn that okay maybe
some people will climb
at dusk and therefore the lighting will
be different without even realistically
having this data and i also optimized
some hyper parameters of the model so
kind of the the standard
uh process of training a model and the
point here is that i'm
not really an expert of this um you know
i didn't go crazy with how many things
i optimized in order to come up with
this model
and i was still able to get pretty good
results
so to show you some examples uh here
i've got the first row corresponds to
the kind of input image
i'm giving to the model and then what
kind of
route the model is giving us its first
prediction and as a second prediction so
we're basically expecting
the same hold or the same route to
appear
in the middle row and as you can see in
the first column
yep it's providing as a first prediction
the same hold so it is understanding
that this is the same route
and very interestingly the second
prediction of this brown hold
uh even though it is predicting the pink
root
uh you can see that that hold appears in
the corner
of it so even it's such a small fraction
of the whole the model was still able to
say
hey this is still a very similar similar
class so
that was interesting uh the second one
refers to actually a slightly trickier
problem where
the first prediction is the correct one
but you can see it's a different hold so
this is where actually users disagreed
about
what starting hold to take a picture of
when defining this route
but even with the few images that i had
the model was still able to understand
okay these these are two different holes
but they actually refer to the same
route and give the right prediction
the third one is kind of straightforward
even though there is that extra hole
visible in the photo
which is not ideal but the model didn't
get confused and the last one is
actually an example where it did get it
wrong
on the on the first prediction perhaps
of the color but for the second
prediction
it still got it right so at least at
least the second prediction is good so
perhaps we can show that to the user
so these were some examples but i guess
you're all burning to find out what is
the overall performance how well are we
doing on our test set and and
all the images that i gathered and
basically it's pretty good um
so you can see here for the uh for
all of the test sets it's pretty high 95
plus except for the test set on the main
accuracy but actually the tesla was
quite small and it did have some
trickier
uh problems there too but as you can see
if you look at top
two predictions accuracy so basically if
you
count something as a correct prediction
even if the second best prediction
uh only was the correct one you get
really high
uh accuracy metrics so we're talking
here close to 100 percent
so when i first saw this i was really
excited about
um the idea that i started here it kind
of gave me
almost justification that okay it was
worth it maybe this idea can really pan
out and maybe uh it's really worth uh
developing
this app so happy ending right
that was a nice short talk about
successful project in deep learning
um and and this is you know where a lot
of kaggle competitions would end and a
lot of other talks with him because you
know we got good performance on the
tessa what else do you need
but if you read the description of the
talk uh you know that my story is a
little bit different and the difference
here is that
i wanted to use uh this model in real
life
i actually wanted to put it on an app
and actually go to the gym and use it
and and see if it works to match these
two these routes together that me and my
friends are climbing
and the first problem i needed to tackle
to bring it into real life is
put into production put it in the app
and the question here
was that well i do have a working model
but do i have a working model inside an
app
and the first uh thing about my model
that made it tricky
was that it was a pretty heavy clunky
model
that i was running so it would take a
long time and it would you know
require a lot of space so running this
model and making predictions with this
model on
the app that runs on a mobile device was
actually
off the table quite soon it's partly
because i used the pre-trained
convolutional base the big model
that i talked about before and it could
have been more efficient there
um but basically we it
and they're out and there are kind of
solutions to this uh as well maybe
you use tensorflow lite which is uh
specifically optimized
in order to run neural net models on
mobile apps but the point here is that
we kind of just wanted to test the
concept at this point we just wanted to
see if people would use it so we didn't
really want it to go down this
complicated path the other option was to
run the predictions on the backend
server instead uh obviously there would
be a cost
uh for the user to wait for the response
a little bit longer and actually depend
on on wi-fi
uh but you know that's the kind of
solution we went down full but
even that wasn't straightforward because
tensorflow 2
you know had just come out it's it we
found numerous bugs along the way and
just wasn't very stable overall
uh so bottom line you know is that none
of this
was a massive deal breaker uh we could
solve it but
that was the kind of first uh feeling
that i got after seeing all those
great accuracy metrics that hang on this
is not the full story like
it's not even though the model is good
how do i put it
on on the app efficiently but i have
more problems
and the second problem i want to talk
about is
dealing with unexpected images because
one thing that might happen when you
actually use the app in the gym
is that people might take a picture by
accident so maybe they didn't place it
on the starting hole maybe they took off
the took a picture of the general area
overall
or perhaps they're just playing out with
the app at home and you know pointing it
to somebody's face or
my face eating for example you know or
you know who
what else people can can think of trying
to use the app for i don't even want to
imagine
so basically in these cases i don't want
the model to
say oh this is route 1 or or route 2.
i actually wanted to you know say this
is
an invalid picture so i wanted to give a
prediction to a class which is kind of
unknown or invalid rather than you know
it's best possible guess what route it
might be
um if it's no route at all and when i
started looking into this
i was actually surprised to find it's
not a very straightforward problem to
solve
uh with a classification model um
and even really good models can struggle
with that so
an example i want to talk about here is
that even state of the art models
uh you know that trained on millions of
images that can train 1000 categories
really well might have a problem with
that and an example of this could be
um where a model is trained to predict a
toilet seat
amongst the 1000 categories with really
high accuracy
and to say that okay this is toilet seat
or not but if it's provided
a plate so and an image of a completely
different class
it doesn't have an option to say i don't
know it will try to give its best
prediction so
you know and plates and for the seats
can look quite similar sometimes so
it's quite likely to give that
prediction so it doesn't have
you know that uh unknown understanding
even though
to us it's ridiculous that it would make
such a prediction now how can it be a
good model if it's doing something like
that
now not to say there are no solutions to
this uh
i think that there's even a talk at this
uh pi data global
talking about this problem and solutions
to it but again none by that
straightforward
none were like that i can implement
something quickly and bring my model
uh to the gym and try out so it was kind
of another sign
for me that just getting high accuracy
isn't enough to be successful
using this app in the gym but actually
the third problem was kind of a real
nail in the coffin
uh and that's when the roots get reset
if you remember i said at the beginning
that that happened so that means i need
to retrain my model
uh with the new classes and kind of
remove
old classes as well and i kind of
realized that this i will need to
retrain my model
right from the start but i thought you
know fruits get reset in chunks every
few weeks
when i will see that users are uploading
you know new routes
i can retrain the model then perhaps
even automate it
and do it more regularly and but that
was actually before
i tried setting up gpu instances on the
cloud
and considering that the costs and even
training one model
was already quite a lot and i was
thinking what will happen with the cost
once i do it
regularly and you know dream big
if the app really kicks off imagine
doing that for multiple
gyms and you know some areas getting
reset
every now and then that would need
basically continuously
training models uh and you know not even
thinking about the synchronization of
all that
just the cost is quite large and this
was kind of the point
and i was like already thinking about
how to set up this infrastructure but
just before committing to
to discuss and this approach i was a
little bit like
wait a second am i am i missing
something here because this just seems
quite complicated overly complicated and
i knew that there are examples
uh out there uh you know that deal with
many more classes than the 46
i was dealing here and once i kind of
stopped thinking about
the technique that i was trying to apply
here and instead of this problem that i
now had a much better understanding of
that i've got these
images and these are all the problems
that i might have with the app
once i started thinking about how do i
solve my problem
in particular well it didn't take me
very long to find out that there's a
better approach to this
and that approach is content based image
retrieval
and the phrasing here of my problem in
this context would be
that given a picture of a hold what i
need to do
is find the most similar image in the
database
and not really allocate it to an
abstract class that is defined by
you know abstract features that are
learned by algorithm
but just literally finding the most
similar looking thing
in the images that i have in the
database and again thinking about my
problems specifically
i am expecting users to upload images of
the exact same thing the exact same goal
because these are the specific
instructions i'm giving to the user
please take a picture of the biggest
starting mode so it should be the same
object
not really an abstract cat or a dog that
you know i could train my mother to
recognize but that might look
different every time this is here
literally the exact
unique and fixed object and yes they can
be from a slightly different angle or at
a different lighting or a scale
if people move but it's still the same
object
and i was surprised to find and
definitely just a surprise for me not
somebody
more experienced is that there are good
solutions to
this exact same problem uh already that
that does not include deep learning
um and and actually within open source
libraries like open computer vision that
have been around for a while but pretty
simple algorithms uh you know they've
been developed since the 70s to deal
with that
so i specifically um here uh
used orb algorithm brute force matcher
from open computer vision but the idea
behind these algorithms is the following
so the first step is that for a given
image
you try to find features in it so kind
of distinctive things that define
what's in it and it's kind of features
and corners tend to
uh sorry edges and corners that tend to
work well
um and the second thing you need to do
is describe them numerically so that you
can do calculations
with it afterwards and these descriptors
of those features
uh are engineered to be robust to that
change in lighting
uh scale or or uh or orientation
uh so that's kind of the grunt work in
these algorithms that deal with it well
and then the third step is to use these
descriptors that you now hold in your
database
in order to retrieve the most similar
image to a provided image so for example
here
if a user provided this white route
image
the white red spot root what you do is
you take
all the features in that image and
compare it to all the features found
in another image and use a distance
based calculation
uh to try and figure out okay how
similar are these features
uh and then at the end when you compared
all these uh different features you get
a total distance between the two
uh images so here we have 238
with a different one it's also quite
high but with a picture with a different
picture but of the same route it's much
shorter
so this this is actually the image that
would be retrieved
and so talking about specific examples
here and how it deals
uh oh sorry one point uh is that another
point i wanted to make is that these
calculations are super fast
unlike like a 20 uh layer neural neural
net model
um and it deals well with the scale here
you can see it's further away but it
still works quite well
lighting is different still captures the
features and with the other one where
the angle is slightly different it still
works quite well
and the overall performance is actually
99
so it pretty much matches uh the neural
net
performance yet out of the 300 images
that i had
only four were returned uh that
actually the closest image returned
wasn't of the correct route
so it matches it but actually what i
want to argue is that it does better
than that it not only matches it but it
exceeds it
and that's because all the other
problems that i had before and
it wasn't really straightforward to deal
with neural nets it's actually much
easier now with cbir
and the first one that it deals nicely
with is
filtering out unexpected images and
that's because of that distance that i
talked about between images
so now when i use this technique and
compare it with
something completely different and it
turns out me eating a cdj it's quite
different from from a climbing hold
um it's immediately obvious that this is
an invalid picture so i can
rule that out and ask the user to upload
a different picture
the second problem it deals nicely with
is dealing with new classes
it's the same algorithm i don't need to
retrain anything
all i need to do is add a picture of
that new hold
into the database and from that point
onwards any new picture will be compared
against it with the exact same algorithm
and
and the soul works quite well um so
no expensive gpu instances to
continuously retrain models needed
to get it for free and the final thing
that it also solves is it's much easier
to deploy
so basically open computer vision has
been around for a while
uh it's it's stable and reliable and as
i said before the
calculations are light and fast uh
straightforward to run on the app
and all of this uh translates in that is
quite cheaper as well
so no gpu instances um you know needed
uh to retrain the models etc
so another happy ending right um
but again you know no no technique is
perfect and there are always problems to
solve
so here for example cbir perhaps
might uh not act abstractly understand
what a hold is and match on the wrong
features so here you can see it still
gives the right prediction but actually
it's matching on the
on the informational plate rather than
the hold itself so if there would appear
another hole with the exact same plate
then it might give the wrong prediction
or perhaps remember that trick example
that the neural net did well with
where the users disagreed which was the
starting hold
cbir because it looks for specific
objects in it
it will think it's a different route um
so again might struggle with that
or black holes might get whiter as they
get chalkier
so chalk is something climbers used to
kind of soak up moisture so
a lot of black holes tend to start
looking white so again
the model might struggle so it's not
perfect and there are problems to solve
but the point i want to make here and
that's the kind of key learning if you
take away anything from this
is that this approach should have been
my baseline this
this approach should have been what uh
what i start with
because it's much simpler it gives
pretty good performance and it's just
perfect for testing that concept you
know it's something
quick that you can use and reliable to
to deploy whereas i kind of jumped in
for the excitement of the technique
thinking at that point it was a learning
project so it didn't really matter what
i use or how i define my problem
but very soon i realized actually i kind
of want to solve the problem and i want
to build this out to actually other
things become more
more important and the other sad thing
about it is that
this is not news uh there's been lots of
talks
uh about this and implied data even so
check out these things there
they talk about this as well in a very
engaging way and i miss them
but i do feel more calm now because i
know that you guys haven't missed mine
and hope you'll do better than me thanks
for listening